[Music]
when
it comes to energy we have a long way to
go
before our utility bills become a thing
of the past
on the kardashev scale we're still a
type
zero civilization but we're closer than
ever to harnessing earth's energy
so what would it take for us to become a
type 2
or stellar civilization how
could we harness the energy of our sun
[Music]
what could prevent us from getting to
the next level on the scale
and how would our lives change
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if we became a type 2 civilization
okay if you're new to the kardashev
scale to put it simply
it's a way to measure a civilization's
level of technological advancement
based on the amount and types of energy
that it can use
as a type zero civilization we are a
sub-global culture
meaning we still get the majority of our
energy from organic sources like
wood coal and oil
in order to reach type 1 we'll have to
master the use of
all the forms of energy on earth not
just fossil fuels
with many advancements in solar wind
hydro and geothermal power we're
almost there to earn a type
2 rating on the scale we'd need to be
able to use
all the power of our sun so
what could we do with it
[Music]
in order to become a type 2 or stellar
civilization
we'll need to build a massive swarm of
energy collecting satellites
around the sun known as a dyson swarm
you can learn more about this in our
other video what if we built a dyson
sphere around our sun
[Music]
but before we start building we'll have
to improve
a lot of things here on earth
there are many potential dangers to
humanity that could stop us in our
tracks
including climate change war pandemics
and even asteroids speaking of asteroids
nasa has been hard at work developing
their dart project or
double asteroid redirection test
in 2021 nasa will launch the dart
satellite
on a collision course with the
near-earth asteroid diddy moon
which orbits the larger and more
threatening asteroid
didimas this collision will
increase diddy moon's orbital speed by
about four minutes
which is just enough time to alter the
larger asteroid
didymos's trajectory away from earth
creating the first artificial meteor
shower
if this proves to be a successful
defense
against threatening asteroids it could
help us pave the way to becoming a type
1 civilization
and eventually type 2 if we're lucky
mind you if we had the power of our
entire sun at our fingertips
we could simply vaporize any potential
threats to our planet
in fact we could move earth out of
harm's way
if we wanted to theoretically
we could control the orbits of
everything in our solar system
using a dyson swarm could also make
other planets more habitable
with the help of these solar satellites
we could carefully control
any planet's temperature by redirecting
the sun's energy
we could start terraforming nearby
planets to give us
new places to live this would even let
us take
interplanetary vacations
anyone up for a ski trip to mars
in fact why stop at mars with limitless
solar energy at our disposal
we could travel almost anywhere in our
solar system
technology at this point would likely
make space travel available
and affordable to everyone right now
a ticket to space could cost anywhere
from two hundred and fifty thousand
dollars
to tens of millions of dollars yeesh
so much for my mortgage we might
even be able to solve our climate change
problems by partially shading the earth
with the dyson sphere
giving us time to heal and rebuild our
atmosphere
with no more air pollution from fossil
fuels we'd be a much healthier and
happier species but before you breathe
easy
we have a lot of work to do here on
earth before we even become a type 1
civilization
and as you may have guessed that's a
story
for another what if